greets everyone I'm all on it welcome to
my channel I am coming at you today from
a hotel in Anaheim for PSX actually Game
Awards was last night PSX press
conference was tonight I will have a
vlog up about both of those and PSX this
coming weekend next week but tonight I'm
doing another reading mean comments
video I actually never intended to do
another one of these but I've officially
been hosting the daily fix for over a
month now and going into it I expected
the comments to be brutal so let's get
to it what it mean people say this time
if Naomi was the DLC Anala is the
microtransaction look he may have spelt
my name wrong but I'm pretty sure this
was a sick but please find someone else
to do these videos this girl is
absolutely the worst no personality at
all she's the first non hot presenter
disliked I personally don't know what
you're talking about
shut up Ilana just shut up but it's
literally my job at this point didn't
talk she could at least she could at
least wear a trash bag over her face so
that I don't have to look at it might as
well get a dude to do these segments I
don't know what this one means I mean
I'm a tomboy that's the thing that I've
always been I may as well be a dude
that's fair all right yeah I'm a boy she
looks like someone used to hit her face
a long time ago the point when she says
she can't wait for venom and it takes a
bit of the weight off they're not being
Wolverine as scripted she never thought
that she is a drone reading from a
teleprompter this one's a fun one I
wrote a pot in one of the scripts about
venom being in Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite making it easier to digest that
Wolverine slash the x-men I'm on it
i 100% wrote that now that was all me I
have known Alana since way before she
had anything to do with IGN she is
awesome but not Naomi she is like a
delicious chicken but IGN daily
is a steakhouse and I want steak not
chicken I love food too much
what weird mouth Viet nose she has a
face for radio where is that busty woman
i J
there were actually been a lot of
comments about me not having boobs or
being flat-chested which for the record
is just objectively untrue but I do make
effort to like wear sports bras and
t-shirts and stuff on IGN videos so that
it flattens my chest like that is
literally the plan so I get this like
weird sense of pride when I get one of
these comments someone tells me I'm
flat-chested and I'm like well i
deceived you you fell for my monster
plan I'm basically Batman attractive
people should host videos mediocrity is
distracting thank you look she's wearing
trendy nerd glasses now IRL this was
actually quite an event
I got prescription glasses a couple of
weeks ago and I don't need to wear them
all the time but it's very helpful when
I'm reading specifically helpful for
playing video games I wore them on to
fix one day and haven't been allowed to
wear them again because the glass too
bad so I can't really wear them on that
show which is fine I can still read the
teleprompter it's just slightly blurry
uh but this book people freaked out man
they're in my bag right now should I
just wear them for the rest of the video
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna see what
everyone however reacts to this hello
Internet I have these on my face now ah
another gloss is coming hi my name is
Alana does a bunch of pics of me online
in my bra and panties but you have to
take me seriously because I'm wearing
glasses now there are literally no
pictures of me online in my Barton
panties not a thing dude in a wig bring
back Naomi or someone hotter she is one
butt-ugly anchor I'm not out here trying
to be a model it's fine I can be a
little ugly
dear IGN my video game news doesn't need
to come from some sexualized blonde who
was supposed to be dreamy IGN gets
attractive girls on purpose and I think
it's it's kind of insulting I think just
knowing that people will hide it and put
it in front of me not because of
journalistic expertise but just to drum
up some cheap views
fun fact I'm one of the only people that
I Chen who is actually study journalism
also I've written for over 30
publications and I've been writing about
video games professionally for seven
years but thank you for saying that I'm
supposed to be dreaming all right I'm
gonna cut this one a little bit short
you guys because if it's not a lot of
variety in these comments no but really
I'm really enjoying hosting the show
it's been it's been really interesting
actually like I think one of the most
unexpected things to me was that I go
into every single morning immediately
stressed we start writing at 9 a.m. we
finish it well usually like 10:15 and
film at 10:30 and it's I don't know I'm
so used to like rocking up to work
eating my breakfast and then like kind
of slowly easing into my day but this is
the opposite of that you were just going
straight away and I think it wakes me up
pretty well actually but it does make
the day's feel like they lost a little
bit longer my room service just arrived
what was I saying oh yes but really most
people have been super positive and it's
been awesome and I wanted to say thank
you to those people your support means a
ton thank you guys so so much for
watching and extra special thanks to
everyone whose name is up on screen
right now for supporting my channel all
righty you guys I'm Alana I'll see you
soon like very early next week when I
have my PSX vlog edited it should be a
fun one
shout outs Wolfenstein 2 for wedding
action game of the year
alright I'll see you guys next time bye